finally i feel like starting to kind of
die out
i feel like a lot of the young artists
that i'm meeting aren't drugged out of
their minds
exactly but for like two or three years
bro like 2017 2018 last year like
it's it was rough because everybody we
would have come by the radio station
would be [ __ ] high as [ __ ] no 100
and not understanding the damage like
and that's why to me that that song like
i said is uh to me the most important
record on the on the project because
it's like not only is is this industry
affecting like the quote-unquote street
[ __ ] that come in and and how they
are with drugs and stuff like that too
um but that's the reason why
even though he's so loved and i love him
too you know rest in peace mac miller
that's why i mentioned his name was yeah
i heard you mentioned his name i i
wonder if you're gonna catch some plaque
for that yeah and
and i might but at the at the end of the
day like i pride myself on being like
one of the most more honest
artists out here and um i love mac
miller and for sure
it's a tragedy what happened but the
reason why i mentioned his name
was to show the industry like it's for
the people that's going to say well
it's just these artists that are
affected by it the way it comes from and
it's not
this is just not just the little clouds
this is a great kid
no matt miller was like one of the
greats he was like one of the a great
greatest and
a great guy and a nice guy in this
industry
in my opinion you know what i mean
destroyed him it's not just the young
boys it's not just the young boys and
that was the reason why i did it i was
like you know there's a chance that i
could catch some flack but i feel like
this is so important
for people to understand is that like
it's not just the littles it's like
this industry affects everybody
especially
the the the kids that are stars young
like mac miller has been in this [ __ ]
since he was like eight
you know what i mean so it's like when
you grow up in this industry you almost
don't even
have a shot unless we start changing how
we approach
kids like these are kids bro you know
what i mean we're putting certain things
in front of their face
and expecting them you know how are you
as a 15 year old gonna be
in the studio with one of your idols and
he offered you a blunt and not hit the
blunt like you know what i'm saying like
it's so for sure it's like we got to
start taking more accountability
or like if you're yeah or and like you
said i mean weed is one thing but like
how are you going to be in the studio
with whoever
and let's say they got zams or they're
sniffing lines like
bro and these are your idols you like i
don't want to look like the guy that's
like you know what i mean like it's the
running joke like oh snoop pass me a
blood i don't smoke but snoop pass me a
blood
like you don't say like that's like i've
been i've done that
but i do smoke yeah but i also like yeah
i'm like snoop passes you though like
how are you
gonna do it exactly
but it's like yeah i think that you know
i've been i've been kind of you know
shout out to future he's one of my
favorite artists but i was kind of
critical of him pretty heavily when it
came to like just
the narrative he was pushing and he's
living his truth through his music but i
just think that
there was just an error of and it's
still going on you know
um but i just feel like there's this
whole wave of kids that were just
influenced by
by like that that kind of [ __ ] like i
think i think
you know the fact like mask off was such
a big song
that is right the whole
[Laughter]
molly burke said they're not bleeping it
out yeah exactly and that's my whole
thing it's like
like for me it's like you know i never i
never mind catching flack if it's
something that i stand on
and it's in my morals you get what i'm
saying like and that's not to say that
i'm perfect because
you know there's times that i rap about
you know what i mean smoking or drinking
or whatever in case i
may be because i do it but i also tell
the other sides of the story as well and
that's all i say for people is like
you know everybody live your truth you
know what i mean but
understand that like when you when
you're giving money and fame and all
this stuff like you still hold a certain
level of responsibility
and if it's artists that i am genuinely
enjoying and am a fan of
i'm always going to hold you accountable
regardless and that doesn't mean that i
don't like you you know what i mean it
just means that i'm holding you
accountable because
you're in a position that you know you
are a role model to somebody you know
what i mean and if your fans
if i catch blackboard in your fans you
know feel some type of way about it
i'm okay with it if it's something that
i morally stand on you know what i mean
so that's kind of where i'm at with it